i have put myself in a little bit of a
pickle
um
so i'm gonna watch the dragon's dogma
stream it's only like 12 minutes which
surprised me
uh and then catch up on final fantasy so
we'll do those both in one video um
and obviously i knew the stream was
coming because of the capcom showcase
and as a result i tweeted this morning
saying
something like okay but what if dragon's
dogma two and um extremely excited about
the idea of it but then realize because
the stream was 3 p.m which is during my
work day i would not be able to watch it
until now
being 8 p.m
and as a result i was like oh i can't go
on social media all day
people know that i love dragon's dogma
but the fact that i even tweeted about
it so if it had happened i'd get replies
about it
it was like oh
that's my bad um
and i've kind of backed myself into a
corner here where yeah i just i avoided
twitter i avoided instagram um
i'm currently looking at a stream
without the title because you can do
that on youtube just in case it was it
was i had to go through effort
to make sure that i avoided dragon's dog
with spoilers
to the extent that i think now
i don't think dragon's dogma 2 is going
to be announced in this video i think
this is going to be a retrospective
which i'm still cool with and still want
to watch but i don't think dragons dogma
2 exists
but now i've backed myself into a corner
so bad
that if it doesn't exist because of the
way that i've hyped this up i'm going to
be like extra [ __ ] bummed out so i
thought i would at least do dragon stalk
me first and then jump over to final
fantasy which i have seen a tiny bit
about um not too much
i'm nervous weirdly but um
let's do it shall we let's do it
this is the dragon's dogma 10th
anniversary
director
of
which i think i know a little bit about
i think he
he had they had planned to make it
before even like dmc3 um and then sort
of got put on hold because of monster
hunter or something
i think it was because monster hunted
further along and they were too similar
i wonder what that was
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
um
[Music]
aspect it was almost like the um
anti-nemesis system
zootopia
okay so maybe i'm wrong about thinking
it couldn't co-exist with monster hunter
it was more just that he moved on to dmc
mode
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and then
okay
maybe this is just a retrospective
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
default extremely intelligent you have
to dumb it down it's all good ai doesn't
start dumb it starts
very touching
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
yeah there are a lot of cyclops
and they start off real hard too when
you first encounter one um
dragon scales pretty well
there are still areas like endgame that
will kick your ass
out no way i didn't know a lot of this
stuff where i guess i hadn't thought
about it
like how these things started
they're also really hot
[Music]
or something come on
oh my god
oh i totally would have just welcomed
the dog yeah he's staring at me sorry
bud sorry
oh my god that we're not gonna see
anything though
okay that's it that's it that's okay oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
i was so
when i saw how long i'd been recording
for and he knew how long the video was i
was like that's that's it that that's a
that's a shame but it was an interesting
video
and then the high of the announcement
and
and then the slightly reeled back in
them
only showing a title screen oh my god
i'll take it holy [ __ ]
dude
oh it's like it's so
i've been waiting for this for 10 years
i've been waiting for this for 10 years
it's like i was so sure it would never
happen
because it's been so long and it's not
that popular
oh my god
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
sorry buddy
oh my god i wish i had more to say but i
don't have anything to say because i
didn't say anything um
other than that i'm extremely [ __ ]
stoked
dude that's like straight up to
literally number one on my list of most
anticipated games that is number one
it's from all of the e3 stuff that's
happened so far it is dragon's dogma 2
callisto protocol
[ __ ] hell
i was so nervous okay
i'm sorry i'm sure a lot of you find
this very uninteresting
i'm gonna give myself a second to
recover
and then we'll jump over to final
fantasy okay i am all right
just very happy it is time for the final
fantasy 7 25th anniversary celebration
stream
um as i was saying i did see one thing
on twitter about this that pertains to
there being news about final fantasy vii
remake
um which i think we were expecting
anyway but i don't actually know what
that news is because again i had to kind
of avoid social media all day because
both of these streams happened at 3 p.m
pacific time and i was working of course
as is the way so i have to catch up
after work so this is just under 15
minutes
i'm excited to see remake part 2 very
excited to see it um i know they've been
crisis core rumors and i [ __ ] love
crisis core
big fan of zack and it also feels like
crisis core was objectively less
popular than final fantasy just
objectively less people played it a lot
of people
because final fantasy 7 is so
mainstream don't even know who zack is
like
a lot of people um obviously hardcore
final fantasy fans know but a lot of
people don't know so it feels like it
would make sense that we would get a
crisis core remake
um
in
timing with square you know really
really remaking final fantasy vii
especially because zach was hinted at at
the end of remake.1 so
i need to stop talking i'm still just
excited
okay let's go
but yeah i haven't i haven't seen much
me on that
excited regardless
[Music]
nine is actually my favorite final
fantasy
but i do like seven
and i like dan disliked
remake
things i liked and things i didn't like
[Music]
i think
i'm really impressed by the storytelling
shift with it
before crisis
[Music]
final fantasy
this is awful
okay crisis core
this is awful square
why have you done this this is so awful
to look at
you're just listing the titles of things
[Music]
and my eyes hurt
there's those boys
[Music]
we get it
we yeah we get it
[Music]
just had to pause for a second the dog
needed me it happens
let us defy destiny
together it's just so hot everyone's so
hot
what is this this isn't remake 2.
[Music]
what have you done
are they just showing us existing
content
yeah
but i'm not your sister
no
let them speak it
like a
very dramatic
oh
it's seven plus integrate
on steam
final fantasy
final fantasy 7 25th
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay cool
bro
that's actually sick
also a big fan of play arts kai i have a
lot of that batman
figures
all right yep
it's so weird when these presentations
like sonic did it too just give me like
merch like
all right
why here
we'll find the match anyway i don't know
that we need it in the conference
it's so weird
a new arrangement cd as well the 25th
anniversary playlist available from on
music oh yay
cool
[Music]
okay
so far i'm hating the pacing of this it
went from
the game's coming out on steam
to submerge
to mobile games
not my favorite
how far through are we
five
minutes banger of an ending i imagine
surely
[Music]
this actually looks pretty solid
the shame that mobile game uis have to
be so cluttered like they obviously have
to be because of touchscreens but
cool though i am uninterested
oh it has tournaments i don't even
really know what that is maybe i should
look into it
i don't inherently hate mobile games i
just only tend to play the ones that are
hello
it's happening
it's happening
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
how good a video games man
mostly
sorry they'll be tapping is because
wound on my head i just had surgery two
days ago and the wound on my head is
very itchy
tapping right next to it helps
i love him so much i think sephiroth
might be like one of the first
characters i was ever attracted to which
is weird because the other one like
definitely my first was bigger morton
scenario
they're not very similar i was not a
legolas girl
i like a scruffy man
[Music]
it's just so hot
[Music]
eva crisis huh
yeah
oh it's ios
is
we already knew about that
it was just a release date has been
announced
it forms a part of the compilation of
final fantasy vii
and a crisis
the price of freedom is steep
you sure did
zach is cloud speaking making progress
i can cut loose right
this is what i'm looking for
this is crisis call
soldier first class genesis
a month ago he went missing during a
mission in wu-tai
you know i've never actually seen you
use that don't you think it's sort of a
waste
use brings about wear tear and rust and
that's a real waste
dude
i love the combat in crisis core too
like loved it
like rank it way up there
gave birth to the man we know as genesis
project g
project
genesis
settle
down zack the puppy
what do you know
[ __ ] reluctant
that's what i remember
i remember doing that a lot
[Music]
not quite
it's a church
by the way what is your dream
to become first
is it
no
to become a hero
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this record scratching
oh my god okay crisis call
protect your honor
honestly considering it was a spin-off
game
i just thought it was so good
reunion okay do we have details
that's way sooner than i expected oh
it's on xbox
series x and xbox one as well that's
interesting
stop it does that mean remake will be
coming back
probably not square does weird [ __ ] go
on
you need the top titles back
this is gonna be remake too that set in
stone the past is forever
but the future even if it has been
written can be changed
so focus on the future not the past
i'm very excited about both of these
things to finish we started so pretty
he wants to reclaim his birthright
and rule over the planet with genova at
his side
yeah we don't know anymore that's the
cool part it's like we don't know what
he wants anymore i figured it was too
late
wait
what are you implying
that i died that i'm some kind of
imposter
it's really exciting it's gonna be so
fun to play through
and see like fan speculation about what
means what and like oh what happened to
you it's i just think it's a really cool
idea
and i didn't expect it at all i didn't
expect the story changes at all
i feel like i failed you
rebuff okay
makes sense
hell yeah so that is just ps5
interesting choice
so crisis core
i'm already forgetting what they called
it final fantasy 7
final fantasy
oh
[Music]
this is unfortunate unclear unclear on
what happened um
i'm really excited about rebirth it
looks gorgeous
i like yeah
i i think it's like what they've done
for the storytelling is such a [ __ ]
cool idea
crisis core what is it actually called
crisis called final fantasy vii reunion
um it's been a really long time since i
played crisis course so to me i was like
oh this looks like crisis call but i
wonder how many things of that are going
to be different like is that tying into
the retelling kind of thing
it seems like it is because it starts
with re as well
interesting a lot to think about still
very happy off of dragon's dogma 2
thought the start of this was kind of
boring and then definitely gave me the
things i was interested in nice to have
some release windows like that's
definitely exciting
very interesting the crisis core is on
xbox and
remake still is not
um
plus again what's the second one called
rebirth still is not
it makes sense that really square does
do that [ __ ] they do they just they pull
that stuff that's just
that's kind of how they do
you know